Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Está de pie ante la portaría
cuando de repente sientes
un picor intenso detrás de la cabeza.
Todos hemos experimentado
la molestia de un picor inconveniente,
pero ¿alguna vez has reflexionado sobre
por qué sentimos picor?
La persona promedio experimenta
docenas de picores individuales cada día.
Pueden ser activados
por todo tipo de cosas,
incluyendo reacciones alérgicas,
sequedad,
e incluso algunas enfermedades.
Y luego están los picores misteriosos
que aparecen sin causa en absoluto,
o simplemente si se habla de picores.
Te estás rascando
la cabeza en este momento, ¿no?
Veamos una de las fuentes
más comunes: las picaduras de insectos.
Cuando un mosquito te pica,
libera un compuesto en su cuerpo
llamado anticoagulante
que evita que la sangre se coagule.
Ese compuesto,
al que somos ligeramente alérgicos,
desencadena la liberación de histamina,
una sustancia química que hace
que nuestros capilares se hinchen.
Esto permite un mayor flujo sanguíneo,
que acelera útilmente
la respuesta inmune del cuerpo
a la amenaza percibida.
Eso explica la hinchazón,
y por la misma razón el polen
puede hacer que se te hinchen los ojos.
La histamina también activa
los nervios implicados en el picor,
que es el porqué hace rascarte
en las picaduras de insecto.
Pero la sensación de picor en sí
todavía no se entiende completamente.
De hecho, gran parte de lo que sabemos
viene de estudiar la mecánica
del picor en ratones.
Los investigadores han descubierto
que las señales de picor de la piel
se transmiten a través de una subclase
de los nervios asociados con el dolor.
Estos nervios producen una molécula
llamada polipéptido natriurético B,
que desencadena una señal
que va hasta la médula espinal al cerebro,
donde crea la sensación de picor.
Cuando nos rascamos,
la acción de nuestras uñas en la piel
causa una señal de dolor de bajo nivel
que anula la sensación del picor.
Es casi como una distracción,
que crea la sensación de alivio.
Pero ¿existe realmente un propósito
evolutivo para el picor,
o existe simplemente para molestarnos?
La teoría principal es que
nuestra piel ha evolucionado
para ser agudamente consciente al tacto.
Por eso estamos equipados
para enfrentarnos a los riesgos del mundo.
Piénsalo.
Nuestra respuesta de rascado automática
desalojaría cualquier cosa perjudicial
que esté potencialmente
al acecho sobre nuestra piel,
como una picadura perjudicial,
un insecto mordiente,
o los zarcillos de una planta venenosa.
Esto podría explicar por qué no sentimos
picor dentro de nuestros cuerpos,
como en nuestros intestinos,
que están a salvo
de estas amenazas externas,
aunque imagina lo enloquecedor que sería.
En algunas personas, los fallos
en las vías responsables de todo esto
puede causar picor excesivo
que incluso puede dañar su salud.
Un ejemplo extremo es una condición
psicológica llamada parásitos ilusorios
donde la gente cree que sus cuerpos
están infestados de ácaros o pulgas
corriendo sobre y bajo la piel,
teniendo picor incesantemente.
Otro fenómeno llamado picor fantasma
puede ocurrir en pacientes
que han tenido amputaciones.
Debido a que esta lesión ha dañado
gravemente el sistema nervioso,
confunde la señalización
nerviosa normal del cuerpo
y crea sensaciones
en los miembros que ya no están allí.
Los médicos están encontrando maneras
de tratar estas anomalías de picazón.
En amputados, los espejos se utilizan
para reflejar el resto del miembro,
que le pica al paciente.
Eso crea una ilusión que engaña el cerebro
en el pensamiento
el rascar imaginario se ha satisfecho.
Curiosamente, eso realmente funciona.
Los investigadores también están
buscando los genes implicados en el picor
y están desarrollando tratamientos
para bloquear el camino de una picazón
en casos extremos.
Si tener un picor inmanejable parece
algo propio de un infierno personal,
Dante estuvo de acuerdo.
El poeta italiano escribió
sobre una sección del infierno
donde a la gente se le aplicó el castigo
de sentir picor por toda la eternidad.